la sem bonjour alors après des semaines
de retard la campagne de vaccination va
pouvoir commencer aujourd'hui
comment doit elle s'est déroulée dans le
pays effectivement droit comme vous
l'avez dit une campagne de vaccination
qui a tardé à commencer comparé aux
voisins marocains ou à leur algériens
qui ont commencé depuis bien des
semaines la tunisie était dans
l'expectative dans des négociations et
des bras de fer diplomatique avec
certains partenaires internationaux qui
fournissent ce vaccin notamment le
laboratoire pfizer
mais c'est avec la russie que le premier
contrat a été signé avec une livraison
qui est arrivé sur le tarmac de
l'aéroport de tunis carthage il y a
quatre jours pour une vaccination qui
doit débuter aujourd'hui ce samedi à
partir de 8 heures et ce jusqu'à 17
heures trente mille doses ont été reçus
pour vacciner à quinze mille patients
recevoir bien plus de doses dans le
courant de la semaine le gouvernement
pense pouvoir vacciner 3,3 millions de
tunisiens d'ici la fin du mois de juin
les paysans ont été invités bien sûr à
s'inscrire sur des plateformes afin de
pouvoir se faire vacciner une
vaccination sur la base du volontariat
plus de 524 me tunisiens se sont déjà
inscrits sur cette plateforme est la
priorité a été donnée pour cette
première vague de vaccination qui débute
aujourd'hui au personnel soignant aux
militaires aux personnes âgées et bien
sûr aux personnes âgées présentant des
maladies chroniques la tunisie a pris
énormément de retard face à cette
campagne à deux vaccinations la raison
pour laquelle le gouvernement voudrait
mettre les bouchées doubles afin de
commencer cette première vague de
vaccination en espérant que ça se passe
bien et attendre la deuxième livraison
qui sera acquis est attendue la semaine
prochaine cinq cent mille doses
devraient être encore livré la semaine
prochaine toujours avec ce même
partenaire ce partenaire russe
donc à partir de 8 heures jusqu'à 17
heures ce que ça concerne tout le pays
et principalement la capitale pour cette
paire première vague de vaccination le
gouvernement annonçait que cette
vaccination sera gratuite bien sûr pour
l'ensemble des tunisiens ainsi que les
tunisiens ainsi que les étrangers par an
résidant sur le territoire tunisien
cb
en direct de tunis merci pour toutes ces
précisions